Welcome back everyone, Toss a coin to your
witcher this is going to be my new Witcher
season 2 teaser trailer for geralt you're
brand-new to the channel, be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos there's a whole bunch
of Easter eggs here, they'll go over and as
you probably guess they have is big plan for
dropping even more footage that I'll explain
Netflix is doing a special Witcher convention
that is calling it which are con on July night.
And it's good to be combined with the Witcher
video game to be a bunch of video game stuff
going on hand-in-hand with the Netflix Witcher
season 2 stuff and based on what they've done the last week.
Like last Friday they dropped the ciri teaser
trailer another dropping a geralt teaser trailer
this past Friday the pie drop a yennefer one
this coming Friday the pie drop the Witcher
season 2 trailer the bigger trailer at this
big convention July 9 to be in a big video
game reveals because CD Project red that it's
going to be a long time before they drop a
new AAA Witcher game.
But the geralt trailer footage here starts
with him inside a dark mansion, that seems
like it based on the other footage it's Nivellen's
mansion from the grain of truth short story
from the last wish so even though most of
the story of the Witcher season two is taken
from blood of elves because they said they're
doing blood of elves for season two is the
next book in the timeline of the Witcher book
series after last wish and sword of destiny,
which they did for most of season one.
As you can see based on some of the casting
announcements they're pulling some of the
stuff they cut from season one in the last
wish forward to season two so that also goes
hand-in-hand with this other image of the
zoetrope the lantern here depicting the two
lovers on the wall also inside that same big
mansion.
And when Geralt or someone else seemingly
uses an igni sign or magic to light the fire
in the fireplace.
And you see geralt's silver sword which we
didn't really see him use that much during season 1.
All those are things that come from.
Nivellen story during the books Nivellen section
being played by none other than tormund giantsbane
from game of thrones.
During season three before they climbed the
wall he boasted about bedding a bear witch
Ygritte shut down hard core, like hell no
you didn't sleep with a bear then during game
of thrones season eight he told that epic
story about the she bear thinking him one
of her cubs and nursing him through winter
so the even funnier thing here in the Witcher
season two is that he's kind of playing a
bear of sorts he is playing a monster.
But I human who's turn into a monster the
story of nivellen the character that he's
playing is like a really really dark witchers
style twist on beauty and the beast most of
you all remember the story because the Disney
versions where a woman is forced to live with
a man that turns into a monster because he's
been cursed something terrible that he did.
But slowly she eventually falls in love with
him and lifts the curse and they live happily
ever after the story of nivellen in the Witcher
books is a way darker and there is kind of
a happy ending but a really dark happy ending
like there no real super happy fun time endings
in the Witcher.
It's always some sad spin on a happy ending
the reason why the short story that that comes
from is called a grain of truth is because
geralt learns part of nivellen's story at
first and makes his own judgments about the
nature of his curse and what's going on.
But then later learns the whole story and
it winds up being so much crazier than he
expected when geralt happens upon his mansion.
He finds Nivellen who tells him about this
curse that he has and how he came to accept
it because he thinks it's permanent any just
live with it for a long time without giving
too much away about the story he did something
really really terrible to a woman a long time
ago in feels like he deserves the curse so
he just accepted it as a woman living with
him who seems like she's either forced to
live there, but it's very mysterious she doesn't
talk her name is vereena geralt starts learning
about her starts questioning her and things
don't add up.
So he's her to get really suspicious of her
thinking that she's a monster to she doesn't
eat human food so eventually geralt the suspect
her a being a bruxa, which is a type of vampire
in the witchers series the take the form of
human women.
So eventually he figures out that she's sort
of the parasite of the situation instead of
it being the other way around.
Like the beauty and the beast story thing
he that she's just using nivellen's curse
energy to sort of feed around the area of
his mansion.
She winds up attacking geralt once he learns
her secret but he slashes her with his silver sword.
Like us silver sword for special kinds of
monsters like vampires that's why normally
you see him using his regular sword.
Because the silver sword is really effective
against humans.
But eventually she does reveal the truth to
geralt telepathically that after Nivellen
gets involved in the battle, geralt still
tries to kill her because he thinks that she's
the villain of the situation until he learns
that she was in love with nivellen and he
was in love with her but she's been mortally
wounded so as she lay dying so that nivellen
won't have to live without her.
She tries to mercy kill him also because he
is the curse she is one \f1\endash to live
with the curse without her it without completely
giving away everything else about what's going
on with the story.
It has this really kind of sad but happy ending
at the same time is very dark in in the tone
of what you would expect from the Witcher
inserted highlights how the going way darker
with the season two tone if you didn't feel
like the Witcher season one was dark enough
but that's what you say the story is a very
dark twist on beauty and the beast.
This is a scene of geralt and ciri walking
through the courtyard at Kaer Moren with them
framing the shot through the monster bones.
Just to illustrate what it is that they do
here at the school the wolf we teach people
how to kill monsters Ciri is eventually trained
as a Witcher.
So she kind of becomes a Witcher and acts
like a wager but she does undergo the trial
the grasses of the Witcher mutations, so technically
she is not a Witcher.
She might wind up getting her sword at the
end of season two.
Maybe season three.
It depends on how fast her go to speedrun
the plot she really doesn't get it till much
later in the story like it doesn't happen
right away when she just starts out training,
but her sword is called Zireael.
Because that's her name in the elder speech.
It translates to swallow.
So that's why her emblem on the series like
when you see them do the emblems of the beginning
of the intros is a swallow.
So basically the sword is named after her.
But nobody that she knows none of her friends
year or geralt or yennefer call her zireael
they'll call her Ciri speaking of which this
is someone getting out of the bath at the
keep, everyone post your geralt tub memes.
This is probably Ciri though just guessing
by the dainty looking foot they did say there
will be more gratuitous geralt tub scenes
during season two.
This is geralt just sharpening regular sword
looking like he's getting ready to train are
getting ready for a fight.
These are actually a very special kind of
purple flower that only grow where elder blood
has been spilled.
So you can assume what's happening here in
the courtyard this is probably Ciri training
in the practice yard and just gets cut bad
enough to spill some blood on the ground.
Revealing her true nature as someone of the
elder blood.
Although Geralt doesn't really keep any big
secrets from Vesimir about Ciri or the other
witchers like Coen, Lambert and Eskel because
during this part of the story they're all
at the keep with geralt and help train ciri
in different ways.
Along with uncle Vesimir, Triss is also their
this seems like her hand reaching out to grab
someone she's mostly there to provide some
magical guidance because ciri is a source
she has great affinity for magical power.
Like she could become a more powerful mage
than the other regular mages on the TV show
and in the books Ciri has all kinds of crazy
powers that they'll probably unlock and reveal
through future seasons the show.
Like she can teleport, she can even travel
through time, although none of the time travel
stuff happens to little bit later in the story.
So not expecting any crazy time travel anytime
soon.
That doesn't even get into her battle with
the white frost that was happening with the
wild hunt all talk about them a second to
this is someone just holding a Witcher medallion,
you see a bunch of them hanging up behind
geralt at the keep in the light here.
These all belong to dead witchers though from
the school the wolf's was kind of like a memorial
another sad reminder about how their order
is dying out slowly because they can't make
any new witchers.
Because they lost the ability to create new
witchers this is them just preparing a meal
at the keep, this seems like it might be our
first look at Vesimir in the background here
is being played by Kim Bodnia from killing
eve.
I would've loved to see mark Hamill is Vesimir
there was so much fan art of that, it sounds
like it almost happened, but for scheduling
issues or whatever wound up not working out
there was also a bit of a virus situation
last year which made everybody shut down filming
several times in the Witcher was no exception
then to shut down filming a couple times this
is geralt and ciri just preparing for another
fight this painting on the wall here actually
looks like it's meant to depict the conjunction
of the spheres with the planets coming into
proximity with each other depicting the crossing
or people and monsters are able to more easily
travel between worlds of the multiverse.
There are special unicorns in the world of
the Witcher.
that are like extradimensional beings that can freely
travel the multiverse any time that they want.
They become a big part of the wild hunt storyline
later on what you learn about the origin of
the wild hunt in the origin of ciri's elder
blood and the race that created it.
Eredin the leader of the wild hunt comes from
that race of elves that created the elder
blood and it does seem like they filmed scenes
with the wild hunt for Witcher season two
see the writing on the beach year so they
do make a brief appearance I believe during
blood of elves when people are mentioning
them, but they don't actually become real
big characters in the story till much later
on sweep I won't see a ton of them during season 2.
And are really sure with this goal is supposed
to be.
But like I said, there's a whole bunch of
other footage we're probably going to get this Friday with
Yennefer's version this teaser like you see
someone with hands in shackles here.
This is yennefer piping captured by the Nilfgaard,
he is being forced to serve in the court of
emperor emhyr I don't think Hassan actor to
play him yet.
We might ask you see him on screen till season
three her future season.
Once he shows up.
They'll be all kinds of stuff that will need
to talk about.
But don't want to get too far ahead of the
story.
He spotted any other Easter eggs during this
teaser trailer that I didn't talk about during
the video though just right them blown the
comments and I will do a new teaser trailer
video when they release the yennefer teaser
this Friday presumably big reminder that a
really big trailer reply becoming on July
9 my full Loki episode 3 video is get post
next week.
Just like normal and rick and Morty season
5 is starting so I rick and Morty season 5
episode 1 video will post Monday morning what
you wafer everything.
Click here for my other Witcher season two
teaser trailer video with the other different
footage and click here for my full Loki episode
2 video.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and toss a coin to your Witcher!